i'm joined now by the german
government's commissioner for
anti-semitism and jewish life in the
federal interior ministry
felix klein welcome you recently said
that the government
is seeing a rise in anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
in connection with the covid19 pandemic
where and amongst which groups is this
taking place
well in times of crisis people tend to
believe
irrational explanations that are no real
explanations like
these conspiracy myths and
the government now observes that groups
that
traditionally don't have any contact
whatsoever with each other
now join forces uh
in uh the protesting uh against the
the measures uh for the protection of
the population uh regarding
uh the the pandemic and uh unfortunately
anti-semitism
seems to serve as a binding
element of all this and this is new and
we have to observe that really
with vigilance what kind of groups are
we talking about
well we're talking about people from the
middle of society uh
people who uh uh are against uh
vaccinating
uh and uh or people who have odd
uh explanations they they think for
instance that the 5g technology
caused the virus but we also see
alongside these people radical forces
extremists and popular forces and
particularly
the right-wing extremists try to
to use the
the the the abroad the miscontent of
these people
for their aims and they want to
infiltrate
anti-semitic
things and theories and uh particularly
they use narratives
that deny or distort the holocaust so
what is the government
doing about this well uh
there is uh of course there are the
intelligence service observe
uh the fason shoots uh they observe the
uh the situation of course
uh the the intelligence services in
germany act
uh without any political pressure they
they do what they have to do
but what the state can do is actually
that the local communities when
a demonstration is registered can
in bylaw stipulate make some
stipulations of
what the organizers of demonstration
have to follow for instance the city of
munich
recently banned the use of the yellow
star
staff juice to be used in in a
demonstration
where people were seen to have to have
these stars
and it was written unvaccinated uh
so so this can be forbidden uh by by the
local communities and
when uh it is used and police can come
in
and and act one of these groups uh calls
itself creadenken
which means something essentially like
contradictory
thinking and due to the rising influence
in that group
of right-wing extremists some german
politicians are calling for the domestic
intelligence services
to officially put them on a list
of potential risk groups and to
exercise much stricter scrutiny do you
think that's necessary and will it
happen
well i think we have a good tradition in
germany that the intelligence services
observe
the situation and they act according
to their decision
making process i think um well if it's
understandable that politicians uh call
for
for that but i think it's uh very good
and the
um legitimacy of uh uh
of an observation by intelligent service
is much higher when it is done
by the services by themselves and
without any political pressure
the use of anti-semitic terminology by
the protesters against corona rules
why that and how does it compare to
other countries in europe
well the anti-semitic narratives here in
germany like in other countries come
from different sources from
right-wing left-wing also even from
islamist
sources but here
it is very often used in uh in the
context of holocaust distortion
and even denial so people see themselves
as victims
and they
think or they they say that they they
feel like holocaust victims and
this is absolutely outrageous of course
if uh if a
young girl that could not celebrate her
11th birthday
the way she would like to do and she
compares herself
to ana frank who was killed in the
holocaust as we know
and that anti-semitic narrative is so
so outrageous here that it has a special
effect in germany maybe more
here than in other countries and of
course we have to
react politically first of all with
repression
and police has to has to come in because
holocaust distortion
is punishable under german law but of
course we also need to enhance our
efforts in
education if you know who anna frank was
you would never compare yourself with
her coming back to the
whole topic of disinformation and also
conspiracy
theories germany is looking toward
elections next year
how worried are you that we could see a
rise
in this kind of interference
in the political system also from
outside the country
well i think there's a there is a real
danger because once again
in times of crisis people are much more
open to
conspiracy uh myths and theories
according to
uh serious uh studies a third of the
german population
uh is open to to these so-called
explanations and of course this is a
field of action for influences
from from the outside and of course this
is very dangerous and this makes
um also the process volatile because uh
also these queer queer inca people
they take into question our democracy
our system some of them really call for
a new
um constitutional assembly which
of course should
show that they deny our system of the
federal republic of germany and
this is really dangerous and we have to
be vigilant
thank you very much